bien estamos ahora en el problema número
7 y dice el promedio del peso de 14
libros es tp kilogramos en términos de p
cuál es el peso de los libros en
kilogramos
ok ayer es nuestra tan difícil si tengo
14 libros y mediante qué y aquí tengo el
libro 1 ya este le sumó el libro 2 ya
este el sumo el libro 3 no voy a tomar
la suma de todos los pesos de todos
estos libros del libro 1 2 3 hasta
llegar al libro 14 porque tengo 14
libros ok
qué pasa si a esto lo divido entre la
cantidad de libros que tengo bueno tengo
14 libros entonces esto no divido entre
14 me estaría tomando el promedio de los
pesos de los libros pero el problema me
dice que el promedio del peso de los
libros de los 14 libros es
esto es igual a p ok y entonces me
preguntan en términos de p en términos
justos de esta p
cuál es el peso de los libros okay pues
aunque te parece si nosotros nos tomamos
la suma el uno más el de dos más el e3
así toda la suma de estos libros que es
lo que tendríamos bueno lo que
tendríamos es la suma del peso de los
libros que es justo lo que queremos pero
esto aquí es igual bueno pues si yo aquí
tengo un 14 aunque te parece si lo paso
del otro lado de esta igualdad
multiplicando es decir voy a multiplicar
todo por 14 me va a quedar que la suma
del peso de estos 14 libros es igual a
14 p entonces aquí está mi respuesta
porque por una parte tengo aquí la suma
de estos 14 libros y aquí lo tengo
representado en términos de p
perfecto este es el inciso
ok vamos a ir aquí el problema número 8
espero que me quepa porque tiene un lado
cartesiano pero creo que no está tan
difícil vamos al otro plano cartesiano y
me gusta este color para el plano
cartesiano tengo aquí a mi edad ya está
por aquí tengo mi detalles ok
y por aquí tengo a mi eje x
ok y vamos a poner que este es el eje y
este es el eje x ok y tengo dos puntos
tres puntos
el primer punto está en el 2,21 entonces
12 menos
1 estoy situado justo aquí y vamos a
ponerle este punto se llama a este punto
se llama am y es el punto 2 - 1 muy bien
por otra parte tengo al punto número c
en el 25
entonces vamos a movernos para arriba 5
1 2 3 4 5 y estamos justo aquí justo
aquí tengo el punto cm que es el punto a
25 y nos dicen que existe un punto b
aunque estar justo como por aquí un
punto b que es el punto medio entre el
punto a punto c que tiene como
coordenadas
y lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale de
ok bueno lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta es que como este punto es de
aquí es el punto medio entre ese y
tantos como a tener como coordenadas en
x2 pues entonces el punto b también va a
tener como coordenadas x2 va a estar
situado abajo deseen o arriba de am pero
justo abajo o justo arriba entonces
tiene como coordenadas de x2 ahora si lo
que queremos saber es el valor de t
recuerda que esencialmente cuando
nosotros tenemos un punto medio estamos
pensando en el punto que está a la misma
distancia tanto deseen como de a tiene
que tener la misma distancia de ce como
de a creo que éste me queda un poco más
arriba pero bueno si tienen la misma
distancia para pagar justo a la mitad
que te parece si nos tomamos el promedio
de los valores del iam cuando yo me tomo
el promedio de dos valores estoy
fijándome en el punto que está justo a
la mitad es decir que te es igual a 5
151 me estoy tomando el promedio entre 2
que esto es lo mismo que a 4 entre 2 lo
cual es 2 es decir que ven es el punto 2
2 y no estaba tan perdido estaba un
poquito pero un poquito arriba este es
el valor de ver el punto medio entre el
punto 2.5 y el punto 2 como a menos uno
es el punto 22 y de hecho este punto si
te das cuenta está a tres unidades a
tres unidades de cm y está también a
tres unidades de 10 y menos uno a tres
unidades de amd entonces es un punto
medio y además ya sacamos el valor de t
tomando el promedio de los valores de
hierro ok
problema número 8 borremos el pizarrón
vamos a hablar del problema número 9
problema número 9 y dice lo siguiente si
camps y lo bueno es que no tengo que
dibujar aquí si cada x 2x
+ 3 no tengo gráfica esto a su vez por x
menos uno es igual a cero y x es mayor
que 1 ok lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale acá lo que quiero saber es el valor
de acá a ver cam x 2 x + 3 x x menos uno
es igual a cero ok lo primero que se me
ocurre es que tengo 12 vamos a ponerlo
con otro color 1
2 ok y tengo tres números
multiplicándose que me dan 0
si tengo 3 números que se multiplican
que me dan 0
yo tengo una propiedad nosotros no
sabemos una propiedad que dice que el
primero es 0 ok ok a es igual a 0 como
en su dado caso el segundo es 0 el
segundo es a 2 x 3 2 x 3 es igual a cero
o en su dado caso o en su dado caso el
tercero 0 o en su dado caso x menos uno
es cero y es que eso es muy cierto si
tenemos a tres números que se
multiplican y me dan cero forzosamente
uno de ellos tiene que ser cero no sé
cuál pero al menos uno debe de ser cero
porque es la única forma de que me dé
una multiplicación cero algo por algo
por cero es cero y es la única forma
entonces o cae 0 ok o 2 x 3 0 o x 10 de
aquí está muy fácil despejar la x
entonces si x menos 10 x tendría que ser
ok ahora de este también podemos
despejar a x si 2 x 30 entonces 2 x es
igual a menos 3 entonces x es igual a
menos 3 sobre 2 ok x tiene que ser igual
a menos 3 medios para que esta expresión
de aquí se haga 0 o en su dado casos acá
es igual a cero pero justo aquí es
cuando vamos a utilizar el segundo dato
que nos dan y recuerda utilizar todos
los datos en un problema x tiene que ser
mayor que 1 en este caso x es igual a 1
pero no es mayor que 1 por lo tanto este
caso no puede ser x igual a 1 hace esta
expresión 0 pero x no puede ser igual a
uno porque x me dicen me restringen que
debe de ser más grande que 1 ok por lo
tanto ésta no puede ser de igual manera
para este me dice que x es igual a menos
tres medios pero x igual a menos tres
medios no es más grande que uno por lo
tanto este valor no puede ser porque me
dicen que forzosamente x tienen que ser
más grande que uno entonces este valor
no sirve
cuando x es cuando menos tres medios
claro que esta ecuación se hace cero
pero en este caso no cumple esta
ecuación y además cumpla que x es mayor
que 1 entonces si este caso no es si
este caso no es no me ha quedado otra
acá es la que tiene que ser igual a cero
y de hecho es justo lo que me
preguntaban cuál es el valor de k
bueno pues no me queda de otra acá tiene
que ser igual a cero y ya esta es la
respuesta de este problema que a igual a
cero que es el inciso b es el valor de k
que hace que se cumple esta ecuación y
además que que sea más grande que uno de
lujo
recuerda que si tenemos varios números
multiplicándose igual a cero debe de
existir al menos uno que sea igual a
cero y para eso pues intentamos hacer
todos igual a cero a ver cuál de ellos
es el que es igual a cero
ok borramos la pantalla y vamos a hacer
el problema número 10
problema número 10 dice si todos los
hombres de la familia william son más
altos que 180 metros de altura son más
altos que 180 y bueno eso por ejemplo mi
familia no es cierto
la familia cam no todos somos más altos
de 180 metros de altura tal vez algún
día si comemos bien lo logremos a la
siguientes afirmaciones son ciertas
todos los hombres de la familia williams
son más altos que 180 metros de altura
me dice el inciso a inciso a ningún
hombre con una estatura menor a 180
metros es miembro de la familia william
ningún hombre ningún hombre con una
estatura menor a 180 metros es un
miembro de la familia william y creo que
eso es cierto si dijera por ejemplo todo
hombre con una estatura menor a 180
metros es un miembro de familia billy
williams
eso sería falso porque arriba me dice
que todos
son más grandes son más altos que 180
pero que dice que ningún hombre con una
estatura menor a 180 metros es miembro
de la familia william por ejemplo yo
mido un metro con 79 centímetros y no
soy parte de la familia williams estoy
muy cerca pero no lo soy porque además
de que pues soy salman khan
no cumplo el requerimiento de que todos
los hombres son más altos que un metro
con 80 centímetros
y tiene toda la lógica del mundo dice
ningún hombre con estatura menor a 181
ninguno de ellos ninguno de los que
estén a nuestra altura de menor a 180
metros es un miembro de la familia
williams entonces creo que la respuesta
visual fue de manera muy rápida que
llegamos a la respuesta es un problema
de lógica y es un problema que tiene que
ver con matemáticas claro pero tiene más
que ver con lógica matemática
ok creo que creo que la afirmación es
cierta número 10 vamos a el problema
número 11
problema número 11 dice cuál es el radio
de un círculo que tiene como perímetro y
ok el perímetro de mi círculo de espn
pero lo que nosotros necesitamos saber
es el radio de este círculo así que
recordemos la fórmula del perímetro de
un círculo el perímetro de un círculo se
saca como api por diámetro o dos veces y
por el radio dos veces tipo de radio y
justo de aquí voy a poder despejar al
radio porque entonces me queda la
siguiente igualdad dos veces y por el
radio esto es igual a pi y ahora como lo
que quiero ser radio entonces voy a
decir que el radio es exactamente lo
mismo que pi entre dos y ok y esto se
puede dividir claro que sí
aquí tengo un pin multiplicando de aquí
un pi dividiendo estos dos se van
entonces me queda que esto es igual a
uno
medio ojo recuerda que abajo me queda el
número 1 no me queda el número 0 me
queda un medio es decir que el radio
debe de ser un medio para que el
perímetro de la circunferencia sea pi y
tiene toda la lógica del mundo porque
así aquí ponemos un medio me quedaría
2000 por un medio pero dos por uno
medios uno y uno por espn entonces ahí
está la respuesta a este problema bien
vamos el problema número 12 el problema
el número 12 espera déjame hacer otra
capa número 12 y me dice lo siguiente
si es proporcional a x cuadrado ok eso
es muy importante y aparecen muchos
problemas cuando algo es proporcional a
otro algo en este caso si es
proporcional a x cuadrada eso quiere
decir que james es igual a x cuadrada
multiplicada por una constante por una
constante k lo que no estamos tomando es
una igualdad donde estamos multiplicando
por una constante entonces en este caso
decir que es igual acá por x cuadrada
estamos diciendo que es proporcional a x
cuadrado y además nos dicen si quieres
proporcionalidad que es cuadrada y si
que es igual a un octavo cuando x
escuela un medio vamos a ponerlo aquí
james es igual a un octavo cuando cuando
x es igual a un medio ok y qué te parece
si lo sustituimos de una vez aquí igual
y podemos encontrar el valor de la
constante me quedaría un octavo es igual
a camps
un medio por un medio elevado al
cuadrado y esto a cuánto es igual un
octavo es igual acá por un cuarto por un
cuarto ahora qué te parece si multiplico
de ambos lados de ésta
de esta igualdad por 4 voy a multiplicar
por 4 aquí y voy a multiplicar por 4
aquí ok de tal manera que esté un cuarto
con este 4 se va y me queda que cuatro
octavos que cuatro octavos es
exactamente lo mismo que acá que por
cierto cuatro octavos es lo mismo que un
medio un medio y bueno esto para que
porque ahora ya tengo de una manera
explícita esta función de la que yo
estoy hablando
james es igual a camps pero acá vale un
medio a un medio de x cuadrada a un
medio de x cuadrada y ahora sí para
cualquier valor de ye o para cualquier
valor de x
yo puedo obtener el otro valor de hecho
lo que me preguntan eso siguiente cuál
es el valor positivo
que toma x cuando oye es igual a 9
medios es decir lo que quiero saber es
cuánto vale x cuánto vale x y ojo me
pide que quise mayor que 0 a si james es
igual a 9 medios
ok pues qué te parece si sustituimos en
nuestra ecuación original me quedaría 9
medios es igual a camps pero acá sabemos
que vale un medio es igual a un medio un
medio por equis cuadrada y justo atrás
lo que vamos es el valor de x pero bueno
aquí me doy cuenta que todo está en
medios así que qué te parece si
multiplico de ambos lados tanto de este
lado voy a multiplicar por 2 como de
este lado voy a multiplicar por 2 para
que se cancele este un medio este 2 y es
de 2 evans es 2 y esto en medio se van y
me queda que 9 es igual a x cuadrada
jaja esto está muy fácil o que x es
igual a más o menos la raíz cuadrada de
9 que por cierto es lo mismo que más
-3 ok x es igual a más menos 3 para que
se cumpla que sea igual a 9 medios pero
me piden que x sea positiva
me dicen cuál es el valor positivo de x
cuál es el valor positivo de x bueno
pues el valor positivo es que tome el
valor de 3 es decir que cuando x es
igual a 3 positivo que vale 9 medios que
es justo lo que yo quería y ese es el
inciso de x igual a 3x igual a 3 es el
valor positivo que yo estaba buscando y
bueno
creo que voy a hacer el problema número
13 en el siguiente vídeo así que nos
vemos hasta la próxima en el siguiente
vídeo seguiré cuando esta sección número